school closures from the coronavirus are
forcing more than 55 million Americans
in kindergarten through 12th grade to
learn from home or at least try that's
disrupting lesson plans for teachers and
students and it's even harder for those
who don't have internet access julie LIF
taught Hames wrote the New York Times
bestseller how to raise an adult break
free of overparenting
break free of the overparenting trap and
prepare your kids for success she's also
now a CBS News contributor we appreciate
that and she's here with us now Julie
good morning so if you consider the fact
that summer vacation already is
something that we know can be a deficit
creator for lower income kids now we
have essentially spring vacation plus
summer vacation learning is disrupted
are we gonna see a long-term reduction
in kids learning and how do they
catch-up come fall Tony I'm so glad
you're focusing right away on the needs
of low-income kids in my community here
in Palo Alto I'm hearing parents say the
online learning isn't rigorous enough
there aren't enough opportunities
meanwhile there are millions of kids and
families in this nation as you rightly
point out that lack internet access let
me tell you where I think we're headed
number one we have as an example
Hurricane Katrina
now close to 15 years behind us where an
entire community was really ravaged by a
natural disaster and yet kids and
families emerged from that resilient
with skills and they're contributing
members of our society today I think
that's an important example of how
humans endure difficult times that said
there's no question that there are
plenty of kids today who cannot access
the content their teachers are trying to
deliver because they either have only
one device in their house if any devices
they might have only one that they're
sharing among five family members so how
is the fifth grader meant to do the
class online when the eighth grader also
needs to do class online and the parent
needs the laptop to interact with their
workplace or they lack Wi-Fi entirely
the good news here is that Common Sense
Media wonderful nonprofit on whose board
I serve has been lobbying
or these kinds of dollars in a stimulus
package to try to ensure that broadband
and Wi-Fi access are delivered
nationwide now this got stripped out by
the Senate but hopefully with a second
round of stimulus that surely is coming
we can fight for the dollars to close
this homework gap that you have very
rightfully pointed out Johnny yeah we
need it we need internet access we also
need a clean well-lighted place for
people to do their work we hope that
people have access to that I want to
bring in Anthony Mason who's like me
working from home today he's got a
question for you Julie Anthony what do
you have yeah thanks Tony Julie one of
the things I wanted to touch on is a lot
of students are experience kind of a
kind of a sense of loss I mean I've got
a college-age son whose was whose
college musical was cancelled proms are
being canceled graduations are being
canceled is should families try to find
a way to honor this or make up for it in
some way
absolutely Anthony I've got a 20 year
old son on day 13 of 14 days of self
quarantine upstairs and an 18 year old
daughter home from college as well and
as a former college dean I have
tremendous empathy for all of the young
people who are not experiencing the
rituals associated with learning that
they have so been looking forward to and
rightly so I struggle when I hear older
people pooh-poohing it and saying oh
those kids don't they realize there are
bigger problems let's see if we can all
summon memories of our 18 and 22 year
old self go back in time and remember
how important the prom or graduation was
for you and bring empathy to the young
adults who have returned to your
household who are rightfully struggling
with what they've lost they're actually
grieving they're grieving the the loss
of what was to be they're also afraid
like we are they're looking to us for
guidance about how to cope with all of
this and you know they sort of are they
have their own anxiety and they're and
they're reading ours but here's one
thing that I'm hearing that that excites
me some schools are saying they're gonna
send caps and gowns home to kids so that
even though graduation can't be on mass
everyone can dress up and in our
families we can put some lights up we
can find some balloons
we can we can do something to create
some kind of ritual in our homes to
support our kids it won't be the same
but it's so much better than nothing
yeah you're right we got to mark these
milestones we can't let them just pass
Julie lift Eames thank you very much for
being here and and gals I'd toss back to
you there's one thing that Julie
mentioned ahead of her appearance that
she didn't get into the appearance
itself when that is that boredom a lot
of kids are bored right now but boredom
is actually a good thing miss King okay
I'll try to remember that cuz right now
I don't know I don't know Tony I'll try
to remember that